Well,
I don't think we'll engineer our way out
of the energy crisis,
but I think if we adopt a series of
prudent policies,
uh,
we may get there and by that I think we
need a lot greater attention paid to
energy efficiency,
which is still the single best way to
deal with the energy situation is not to
use it.
If there's a way to,
uh,
to do so.
And I'm not talking about,
you know,
sitting in the dark,
I'm talking about simply a better
technology that gives you the same bang
for the buck.
But if we focus on energy technology,
if we moved towards cleaner vehicles and
our transportation sector and our
electric utility sector,
I think,
uh,
you know,
we can get there,
but it's a,
it's a hard slog because,
um,
while we talk about,
you know,
needing to reduce our energy consumption
because of concerns about climate
change,
I always like to remind people that
they're roughly one point 6 billion
people in the world who have no access
to electricity and even more who have no
access to commercial energy.
And we can't forget those people.
As we,
uh,
deal with our own part of the problem.
Well,
it's certainly not,
not only not fair from a human,
a human point of view,
but I think it's more ominous than that.
I think in the kind of world we live in,
in modern communications and people who
have very little,
certainly aren't unaware of how those of
us that have very much live and I think
at some point we're going to start
seeing a increased political violence
and potential increased risks of
terrorism rather than just have people
wallow in their misery and kind of die
unnoticed by the rest of us.
Well,
some of the developing countries,
of course being very poor countries,
I'm thinking particularly maybe some of
the Central African countries,
uh,
they're problem is they don't have the
resources to do what they need to do,
to adopt,
to,
uh,
to climate change or to take actions to
mitigate the effects of climate change.
Many of these countries are suffering
from deforestation or growing incursions
by the desert,
what we call desertification.
And increasingly many,
many parts of their countries are
uninhabitable.
We're beginning to see climate refugees
move across international frontiers in
response to these changes.
So I think we need to go in with
renewable energy technologies,
uh,
that makes sense given the local
environment and try to provide a better
modicum of life,
but also to dissuade them from
continuing to denude,
uh,
the remaining forest that they have.
Well in many parts and many parts of the
emerging market countries,
uh,
I think wind and solar offer probably
the two greatest potentials,
uh,
certainly all of North Africa has a
great solar resources and a lot of the
desert regions have pretty consistent
wins.
So you want to start with that and then
you need to use those technologies,
you know,
to help with wells,
develop water supplies and wind and
solar,
uh,
generated electricity can help alleviate
those kinds of problems as well.